so Ellen O'Brien and you're coming to us
I'm just going to guess from Ireland
right
yes I am okay where are you in Ireland
right now um so I'm in uh Tullamore so
it's in the Midlands oh how far are you
from Dublin it's about an hour roughly
okay Ireland's not huge so a lot of
things are an hour from something else
isn't that right yeah so I'm an hour
towards the middle tell them more
literally in the middle of Ireland
Tullamore sounds like a magical land
doesn't it it's like with filled with
Pixies and leprechauns and unicorns
Tullamore has a very just a just a fairy
tale kind of feel to it there's
definitely some strange creatures
um
sorry Ellen those are called Irish
people
I have some experience so okay your name
is Ellen O'Brien
um I'm in O'Brien as well as as you may
know and so we're probably distantly
related in some way yes we definitely
are yeah everybody's related so I know
that's that's the problem I found out a
few years ago that uh because I've got a
DNA test and found out that even though
I've been living in this country for my
family has at least for about 150 years
I am still 100
100.00 Irish because it's the skin color
and the hair yeah and all the relatives
we we didn't Branch out no one no one
got creative uh with their with their
life partner Everybody Just Married the
person who was brushing their teeth next
to them in the bathroom
150 years after of that and look at me
so
all right so Ellen I'm trying to
understand a little bit about your
background tell me about your parents
what are their names
um so my dad Ray he was born
um an O'Brien
um and he met my mom when he was 21. who
is Tina O'Brien
um wait a minute
was she born Tina O'Brien or she know
she took his last name no she was born
teen O'Brien oh my God wait a minute an
O'Brien met and married an O'Brien this
is what I've been talking about
this is the problem what are you guys
doing not we're not roaming far from the
house that's for sure you're not roaming
far from your family
they're not related of course not oh
they're both from teeny tiny town in
Ireland and they're both named O'Brien
but of course there's no second
relationship
sorry about that no they're I'm sure
they grew up blocks from each other
yeah they're five minutes away
well uh
uh I uh I'm one to talk because as I've
said right my my family uh lots of
O'Brien's marrying O'Brien's oh well I
turned out perfectly normal
yes you did perfectly normal oh you're a
very good lawyer lawyer and liar
you're gonna make a great lawyer